Today,
we will learn about noncompete clauses
by examining the case of data management
versus green noncompete clauses are
increasingly relevant in our economy.
The extent to which they
should be enforced is the
subject of our lesson today.
Before we turn to the facts of the case,
let's talk a bit about noncompete clauses.
A noncompete clause or a covenant not
to compete is a provision under which an
employee agrees not to enter into or
start a similar profession or trade in
competition against his or her employer.
Why might an employer want their
employee to sign a noncompete clause?
Well, the main reason is that employers
may be concerned that their employee,
uh,
might reveal confidential information,
trade secrets or marketing strategies.
Uh,
employees of course sign non compete
clauses because it's a condition of
employment for at least some employers.
In cases where employees
have some leverage,
they might sign a noncompete clause in
exchange for a higher salary or benefits
of some kind from the employer.
Employees might be willing to give up the
freedom of working for a competitor in
order to get a good job that might
provide them with some extra chaining or
hands on experience.
But a noncompete clause that's too broad,
either in its temporal
or geographic scope,
might prevent an employee from finding
any alternative employment in their
chosen field.
The facts and data management versus
green or simple defendants and employees.
Green and Van Camp signed a covenant
not to compete against plaintiff and
employer data management in Alaska for
five years following their termination.
Shortly after their termination,
defendants began to compete with the
plaintiffs who sought injunctive relief.
The trial court granted a preliminary
injunction and then summary judgment in
favor of defendants.
The instinct court clarified the law
to be applied and remanded the case.
There are two main issues in this case.
The first is whether the covenant was
overbroad and therefore against public
policy.
The second is whether the covenant as a
result of its over breadth is completely
unenforceable.
On the first question of whether the
covenant was overbroad and therefore
against public policy.
The court answered yes.
Under English common law overbroad
covenants not to compete.
We're under unenforceable under the
public policy doctrine. In effect,
preventing covenants that are
overbroad sets a ceiling or a cap on,
uh,
on their length covenants not to compete,
must be reasonable with regard to both
their length and their geographic scope.
There's a mandatory ceiling on the,
on this scope.
In this diagram you can think of,
uh,
there being a mandatory a ceiling on
the maximum duration of the Covenant and
uh,
not to compete.
The court finds that the covenant not to
compete for five years goes beyond this
cap, uh, and goes into
the non contractable zone.
Okay.
This immutable ceiling is similar to
the treatment of unconscionably high
markups and the treatment of
unconscionably high liquidated damages,
uh, amounts, uh,
that operate as penalties
in these other contexts.
The law also places mandatory caps on the
markups or the price or on the size of
liquidated damages.
But the default rules are very different
in these, in these different contexts.
The default duration of a covenant
not to compete is zero years.
If you leave out a covenant,
then there is no duration nuts,
you can immediately compete,
but the default price
is a reasonable price,
not a zero price and a default
damages our expectation,
not zero damages.
So from these examples,
you can see that contract law,
uh,
can not only decide
what I default rule is,
but it can also limit the
alternatives to the default,
which the parties can choose by putting
on ceilings or floors and or somehow
limiting what other
options they they go for.
Why is the mandatory ceiling imposed here?
Well,
one reason is that restraints
against Labor Race 13th Amendment,
uh,
type concerns.
Recall that the 13th Amendment van
slavery and involuntary servitude in the
United States.
One argument is that the covenant not to
compete are unconstitutional restraints
on people's ability to provide
their labor in an open marketplace.
We also don't want a former employee
to become a ward of the state.
If employees are laid off and can't find
another job because of the covenant not
to compete,
they might have to rely on social security
payments or welfare payments of one
type or another.
This means the rest of society
picks up the tab for the noncompete.
Generally, when you see a mandatory
limitation on freedom of contract,
you should ask whether the limitation
can be justified in terms of extra
analogies or paternalism concerns.
You can argue that both are in play here.
Okay.
After the court has found
the covenant to be overbroad,
it must address the second question,
what to do with the contract.
The court often to reasonably alter
the covenant to make it enforceable.
The court has three main approaches to a
covenant that is overly broad that goes
beyond the mandatory ceiling.
First,
the court can choose not to
enforce the contract at all.
This court does not like this approach
because it quote may produce unduly harsh
results on quote,
but you might argue that we want harsh
results for deterrence purposes to deter
employers from putting in overbroad
covenants, not to compete.
The court's tone reflects its attitude
about the nature of the employers and
maybe the employee's behavior.
This may be a context where employers
actually know the law and the risk of over
breath. Second, the court
can use the blue pencil test.
The Blue Pencil allows alterations only
by the deletion of specific words in the
covenant.
The court rejects this approach because
it's too dependent on the language of
the parties that the
parties happened to use.
The Blue Pencil rule is
a very mechanical rule,
but because some courts rely on it,
a parties might consider fallback language
indicating that the covenant will be
enforced for the longest period possible.
So party might say a covenant might read
this covenant lasts for five years or
for the longest period allowed by law.
The Blue Pencil rule arose because courts
are disinclined to rewrite contracts
to add in their own language into it.
With the Blue Pencil rule,
courts don't have to write any new words,
they just have to strike offending words.
Sometimes a crafty court might be able
to strike a word or even just a digit.
For instance,
a 10 year noncompete clause might
become a one year noncompete clause by
striking the number zero.
The last approach,
the one adopted by the court in Green is
the reformulation of the contract to a
reasonable breadth. In this case, the
court adopts this approach and uh,
unless the contract was
not drafted in good faith,
if it was drafted in bad faith, the
contract wouldn't be enforced altogether.
When parties violate a
mandatory limitation,
there are two generic legal responses.
First,
the law can substitute the provision
that comes closest to what the parties
contracted for for that result is depicted
in this slide by moving the parties
to a covenant just
below the mandatory Cap.
Alternatively,
the law can punish one or both of the
contractors for violating the mandatory
limitation.
That result is depicted in this slide
by moving the parties to a covenant with
zero duration. It's a poor length with
regard to an employer's preferences.
Then what the employer might have been
able to contract for non compete clauses
also appear in the sale of a business.
Well,
why would a buyer and seller of a
business want a noncompete clause?
Usually the vendor of a business will
promise not to compete with the purchaser
to ensure the value of the
business being sold. For instance,
suppose that Robert
Sells Sally his bakery,
Sally will likely demand that Robert
sign a noncompete to not open up a new
bakery next door because that would
undermine most of the value of the bakery
salary.
Sally just bought
the covenant not to compete has been the
source of prolific litigation and Ohio
Court once wrote that there is so much
authority on noncompete that it can be
compared to a c that will
drown the legal researcher.
US jurisdictions approach
noncompete clauses differently.
While the majority of us states
recognize and enforced various forms of
noncompete agreements,
a few such as California show great
hostility toward the enforcement of
covenants not to compete in general,
courts focus upon two
aspects of a covenant,
whether it protects some
legitimate interest of the promise,
see and whether it's reasonable and scope.
When it comes to the sale of a business,
courts tend to be more favorably disposed
toward covenants that are ancillary to
the sale load business.
Then toward those that restrict and
employees competitive activities. Uh,
covenant ancillary to the sale of a
business is usually seen as protective of
the goodwill being sold with respect to
the employee's covenant where the Party
does not have a special or unique skill.
The usual attempt is protect by
precluding the use of trade secrets,
confidential information,
customer lists, and the like.
The reasonableness test deals primarily
with the area and types of companies
covered as well as the
duration of the covenant.
And it is here that efforts are
frequently made as in the instant case to
convince a court that the excessive
parts should be excised leaving and tack
that which is reasonable.
Both as with regard to space and time
efforts are thus made to sever or divide
the legal portion from the
portion which is illegal.
The geographic scope is increasingly
problematic because in the internet age,
many manufacturers find
themselves competing, uh,
online with producers from
anywhere in the world.
In summary,
a noncompete clause or covenant not to
compete often appears in an employment
contract or a sale of a business.
Noncompete clauses cannot be overbroad
and against public policy if they are
overbroad at court may choose to
not enforce the clause entirely.
Delete certain provisions using the blue
pencil rule or reformulate the contract
to what would be reasonable reformulation
is often the preferred approach
because it's not overly
harsh and is very flexible.